I guarantee you Jon Gruden are good and
I are gonna know what a Raider looks
like and smells like he can play split
in he can play flanker he can play in a
slot he can return punts and sell
popcorn a halftime nope to be a good
example there's one obligation you have
with me and that's leadership Oakland
Raiders trying to turn around a four and
twelve season from 2018 making some
moves obviously one of the biggest moves
of any team this offseason getting
Antonio Brown from the Pittsburgh
Steelers and also having three
first-round picks to use I mean they
stole this guy from the Steelers for a
three and a five now they're paying him
a lot of money but they did steal him
from the standpoint of draft pick
compensation to come out of this
offseason Chris with Antonio Brown and
three first-round picks that's an
amazing accomplishment for Jon Gruden
mike Mayock well I mean amazing you
could sit here and argue the Oakland
Raiders won the offseason in a lot of
ways I mean not only Antonio Brown Trent
Brown right who gets paid to be the the
highest-paid offensive lineman in the
history of football he's gonna play
right tackle okay
so that was amazing to get Tyrell
Williams from the Los Angeles chargers
who's a really awesome receiver to add
to the passing game cuz there's no Jared
Cook this year let's not forget they
lost him and then okay Josh Jacobs now
in the offense man Gruden's got all the
toys he wants to have a Jon Gruden
successful type offense there so the
Oakland Raiders fans the team everybody
they should be excited about what they
got on that side of the ball and then on
the defensive side of the ball made some
nice moves too you know getting a Lucas
Joyner of course in the in free agency
was huge drafting the Abrams kid from
Mississippi stayed at safety at the end
of the first round I think he's gonna be
an instant impact type player so they've
done a lot of good things and of course
Cloudland Ferrell I'll pick number four
if I had to be wound it picky about one
thing I don't trust about the Raiders
still okay Mike is one quiet is I don't
know still if there's any real
difference makers in their front seven
there's a lot of good or a lot of who
there's potential there
I think they clearly over drafted
Cleland Farrell at number four I really
do
I don't think he's gonna be the type of
guy that's gonna get twelve and fourteen
sacks a year I think he's kind of a six
to eight sack of guy year who's just a
really good player and a good leader
like we heard in that mashup with mike
Mayock so that would be my one question
I thought they might get in this Ezekiel
anza sweepstakes a little bit because
they have so much money with the cap
that maybe they would throw him enough
money to get him on the roster too but
that's the only thing I worry about 13
sacks last year Mike from the Oakland
Raiders I mean that was worse than
football by a landslide second to worse
than football was 30 sacks
so that's 17 less sacks than the second
worst team in football on defense that
is not acceptable this day and age in
the NFL I still think we wouldn't be
saying Cleveland Pharoah was over
drafted if mike Mayock was still at NFL
Network but that's a discussion he's
already told us they're over drafted
post draft I mean he came out and told
you that I understand he'd be on the
radar more but he said they were trying
to trade down with the Miami Dolphins so
that tells you that the value wasn't
there but either way they wanted the
player and it was the only way they
could juggle around getting all three of
those positions I think in the first
round and I'm not mad at them for doing
that
you mentioned Trent Brown and the money
they paid him highest-paid tackle in NFL
history how surprised were you at the
news that they're gonna put him on the
right side not the left not shocked I
think really naturally that I mean
that's where he was when he was with the
San Francisco 49ers yeah and he wasn't
good no he wasn't bad I mean when are
people gonna realize that the reason
that offensive lineman placed so well in
the Patriots system has something to do
with the system and not the lone miss
Garnett yet the Nate's older if the
Nate's older debacle wasn't enough last
year when the Giants paid him a ton of
money and it didn't work what are the
Raiders thinking is I mean I could at
least get behind the idea if you're
gonna play Trent Brown at the position
he played with the Patriots but you're
moving him back to the side of the line
where he's stunk when he was with the 49
I think stink hour stunk is a little
harsh he wasn't he didn't he was bad
enough to get trained well he was I
don't think there was more to it than
just play on the field there in that
situation that got him traded to so I
don't know if the play totally you know
is justifiable there and that Rimbaud
either way I think your point about the
Patriots and Dante's car Nekia who it's
either him or Mike Munchak for the best
offensive line coaches in football they
always get the most out of their players
it doesn't matter who they are so I hear
you I don't know if I would have made
Trent Brown the highest-paid tackle in
the history of football I don't know
about that but they did draft Colt
Miller in the first round in the 2018
draft so I'm sure they want to keep him
and since Trent Browns the veteran who's
done both they've probably thought it
was safer to move him back to a position
at least that he's done before and right
tackle is usually your better run block
blocker to Mike and I think that's
probably the logic behind that as well
one guy we didn't mention unless I
wasn't listening to you which happens
from time to time vantes Burfict you
mentioned the front seven I did you know
that one of the reasons they stuck with
him so long in Cincinnati he has that
edge he has that vibe he gets the guys
behind him and Bengals Raiders playing
this year me and think about it you take
Montez perfect from the Bengals how
bland team like the Bengals and he's the
way is you put him on the Raiders and
that's cranking it up to 15 more p.m.
tonight right after this
[Music]
you
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports